on the third day of digging
police were said to have uncovered a
hidden cellar they hoped it would
provide the crucial evidence they need
sniffer dogs joined the search in the
garden of a secluded holiday chalet
where the suspect once lived
police were hunting for clues to the
disappearance of madeleine mccann
clinton
officers sifted piles of soil dug from a
hole
15 meters wide they also used ground
penetrating radar and later brought in a
drone
[Music]
three skips were removed not all of them
full drifter christian b is the main
suspect
in what the german prosecutor calls a
murder investigation
madeleine vanished 13 years ago during a
holiday in portugal
the suspect was living there at the time
soon after madeleine disappeared
the suspect moved here one police theory
is
he drove her with him on a journey of
more than 24 hours
[Music]
question it's difficult to judge the
importance of this search
it's wide seemingly unfocused
perhaps even a fishing expedition in a
location that police have known about
for three years but they wouldn't
normally
spend such time effort and resources if
they didn't have credible information
that they're likely to find vital
evidence here
police wouldn't say if they'd found any
evidence or whether they're to search
anywhere else martin brunt sky news
hanover